I kind of understood Men in Black a
little bit, but I didn't want to make
Men in Black.
That was the next year after
Independence Day.
So I didn't want to make two alien
movies back to back.
How did he convince you?
Steven Spielberg sent a helicopter for
me.
You god damn liar.
Yeah.
I was in New York. To talk to you.
To talk to me, to talk.
You like it landed at his house and he
had me at hello.
Well, yeah. You can't say no after you
get off the helicopter. Yeah, he
Get off the helicopter at his house.
He says, Come on.
What are you.
And it was the first time I'd ever had
lemonade with carbonated water.
Yeah. You can't say no.
You can't say no to that. There was
lemonade with carbonated water and--
But you had to act like you had it
before.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was like, Yeah, this
is regular.
That's good. Shit.
Yeah. Is this carbonated water?
Just like my grandmother used.
To make carbonated water?
I would say.
That. Yeah. This is good shit, Steve.
But, yeah, he. He flew me in and he, he,
he said the coldest shit.
He said, he said tell me, tell me why
you don't want to make my movie.
And he was the producer and I was like
and he, he, he put the ellipses at the
end. It was the dot, dot, dot.
Tell me why you don't want to make my
movie. It was the dot, dot, dot.
If he had continued, he would have
said, Joker, you know, I made Jaws.
Right? Yeah. Or, you know, I.
Made E.T..
Or Motherf*****.
Motherf*****. He might have.
Said. He might have said he's
respectful. Why don't you want to make
my movie?
Well, you don't want to make it.
Like, a very low tone to it.
And he. I walked in his house, and he
had the Jaws poster and the.
Was the, Jurassic Park.
He had everything. So it was just so I
would know.
What's your answer?
What's my answer? And I was like, you
know, I didn't want to make two alien
movies back to back.
I didn't want to go from Independence
Day to Men in Black, you know, I felt
like I would I didn't want to be the
alien guy.
But I mean, honestly, it's a it's a
worry that we have because I think the
the biggest thing that we think about
while having a moment at the top is,
well, how do you stay at the top?
And I don't want to make mistakes.
I definitely don't want to keep doing
the right thing. I don't want him to
think that this is the only thing I can
do. I want to expand and do more.
So I understand that logic.
I understand why it would be worried.
I mean, for him, it's just basically
like, I'm Steven Spielberg and you're
protected. Yeah. Don't make bad stuff.
Yeah.
And that goes back to one of the one of
the earlier questions.
It's like. It's a team sport.
You know, and.
The there's a couple of really critical
things. It's like, who is at your right
hand? Like who your friends are, who
you're with every day will make or
break your dreams.
You cannot build a career.
And you probably you know, I'm going to
speak specifically from my experience,
but you probably can't do much of
anything in this life at a high level
without a rock solid team.
And in your in your rise of it.
Did you see that or were you the
individual that felt you were doing it
by yourself?
Now. I never I never really thought I
was doing it by myself.
I knew that I had to be the tip of the
spear in terms of discipline.
I knew I had to be the tip of the spear
in terms of direction.
But but I always knew that I needed my
squad. You know, we've talked a lot
about, you know, our our parents.
Absolutely. And, you know, my father
was military. So it was very clear to
me that there was a commander.
So the commander is in charge.
But if you ain't got nothing to
command, nobody is willing to follow
you. You got nothing.